We ran into a tragedy,
however,
when I was four,
my one year old sister died suddenly
from croup form of pneumonia,
I guess,
and she was my mother's
attempt to be born again,
you might say through her daughter
because he's great.
Wives,
lived very tough lives giving how their
husbands were working and when she lost
her beloved daughter,
she went into very deep mourning.
And I,
uh,
as a child who normally
thinks we,
I think we think of ourselves as the
center of the solar system.
Everything revolves around us.
We're responsible for everything.
I guess I wondered why as my mother
withdrew and to the deepest,
deepest depression psychologically what
I did to cause her to abandon me,
added to my complexities,
I guess you'd say I formed a,
a,
a pattern of having to achieve and
having to be perfect so I could somehow
regained her,
uh,
her affection and her attention and
that's had some good points and had some
bad points because trying to achieve
perfection can be a productive.
It can also be a very destructive
process after awhile.
So she had quite an impact on me.